hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
reborn now I have had the worst time
trying to get this video to let me
explain how bad this morning is gone I
got up at 5 a.m. this morning because I
wanted to record this video and get it
for 8 a.m. and I was gonna do it I was
gonna beat it and everything was gonna
be fine and everything was going fine I
was learning the map I was learning
everything about chica I was learning
how to beat her and it got pretty easy
and I actually memorized every location
of the page and I did this because if
you beat all of the animatronics you get
a special secret bonus then I'm gonna
show you guys in a little bit but at the
end of the bonus it just closes the game
and that may not seem like a bad thing
but a little behind the scenes on Let's
Plays if you're recording and I'm not
recording in windowed mode I'm just
hooking into the game directly if it
closes
without me stopping recording that's
like a 50/50 shot of it just corrupting
the file so I've been recording for two
hours and that chance of corruption goes
up the longer you've been recording so I
lost it and I could recover it but it
usually cuts off the last like 10% of
the video which was the bonus so then I
went to do it again and I was trying to
play cheek again and I thought I was
losing my mind because I was wandering
the woods and there's no pages cuz once
you beat it the pages are gone and
you'll have to reset the game to do it
again then so I have had I am so sorry
that this video is so incredibly late
that things have been off schedule
because I've also been working on my own
map hasn't been able to edit for me for
like three weeks so I've been doing
everything with the trips and the other
projects that we've been working on so I
have been buried under work which is why
I got up at 5 a.m. cuz I had to work
late last night and I didn't have to
have to record and then I got to get up
early I was gonna be totally on schedule
and everything was gonna be fine but
everything that could go wrong has gone
wrong
but what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you guys this bonus and then
I'm going to reset everything and beat
chica again so that you guys can see the
proper way to do it and it's relatively
simple so I love you guys so much you've
been so good to me and all that jazz oh
I just want to relax with you guys but I
know that I can't oh wow
welcome to the real party everybody
thanks for being here and if you look to
your right you'll see a door that leads
to nightmares so this is the special
bonus and you go do this weird hellscape
that kind of looks like the bottom of
subnautica and that lava cavern where
supposedly via the sea Emperor's gonna
be here the sea dragon or I'm not 100%
sure which giant monstrosity is gonna be
there but it's gonna be big and it's
gonna be evil just like the area in here
and if I recall ah [ __ ] you okay got him
alright that's cool I got my defense up
just in time everything's fun and
fantastic and free and if you go over
here you'll notice boink
oh it's still in hell still a perpetual
landscape of hell oh man I tell you if
this if this crashes again I'm recording
in windowed mode I'm very much
meticulously making sure that I'm
recording in the proper way that this is
gonna work 100% because man it has been
a morning of hell and I've got so much
more work than I need to do but you guys
come first hey what's that behind you
I've got such an incredibly long day
ahead of me but I'm just you know I I'm
not begrudging doing Let's Plays like
I'm not saying that but for some reason
you'll occasionally and everything you
do no matter what art school and like
jobs whatever you'll have one of those
days where everything that is [ __ ]
in the world will culminate all your
arch nemesis I will get in one room oh
yeah I forgot all your arch-nemesis will
get in your one room like this hi foxy
phantom foxy digital weirdo foxy some
kind of foxy derivative that I don't
know about and they will just destroy
your existence where am I going oh hello
my flashlight doesn't seem to work I
don't know and there you go game just
closes on you like that it's cool right
okay huh so that was this special secret
and now the developer is gonna be
working on the game in full but what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna load the game back
up and then I'm gonna show you guys
everything on beating chica so I'll be
right back okay so now I'm gonna race my
progress which is always a fun thing to
do
yeah boink boink what away oh I'll get
worrisome selectively I can just play
chica again oh I don't have to do I
wasn't gonna do them all anyway but now
it actually looks like I don't have to
do them all oh thank goodness okay so
with chica it's it's a everything does
not randomly go different places all the
pages are in the same place at least I
hope so unless it changes again I have
no idea but the pattern is relatively
simple because it involves a lot of
staying on the path except for the very
beginning and then the very end and
some point in the middle but for the
most part everything that you need is
generally in a similar area to where you
spawn in it now I didn't spawn where I
usually spawn so I got a worry at myself
I think there's probably a page ah damn
and of course I'm getting turned around
I wouldn't be able to show you guys
exactly what to do uh all right let me
just die to spawn okay here we go this
is usually the typical spawn that you'll
get and like the most often so you get
this one first which has like some
Japanese ready and you can run like that
was uh those a misconception from me you
can you can run literally all you want
and she won't mind all you got to do is
make sure you look at her every once in
a while to appease her ego and then
everything will be hunky-dory after that
no I I got turned around again where the
hell is the second one I'm a bad guy oh
man
[ __ ] are you kidding me oh there it is
okay I got it all right sorry about that
I just keep getting turn around why is
this game [ __ ] with me why am this
game dick with me okay you get that one
you get the doge Eidos you get the Doge
Eidos over there keep looking at or you
get this one over there and bam you've
got four right off the bat now you just
from here on out you can just kind of
follow the path going round and round
until you find everything you need and
most of them are either on this path
that you're on or they're very quickly
offshoots of the path so coming up here
we're gonna reach a light that's another
landmark that you can use the only light
that's actually adjacent to the fence
it's actually kind of pointing towards
the next page that you need is so long
as you don't get turned around here if
you go perpendicularly out not quite to
the path but if you go perpendicular out
from there oh [ __ ] sorry got a little
turn around you grab this one you can
get that and then you need to get back
on the path you can scoot ahead a little
bit you don't have to go right back to
the light go back to the light if you
need orientation because it can lose you
and then the next one's right on this
tree over here and then you just follow
the path continually you'll get to the
page that's on the fence and then you'll
be in the general area for everything
else
now the misconception that I had is
every time I loaded up the game I kept
getting these pages on the lampposts and
those pages on the lampposts there's
only like three of them or maybe even
two of them so when I loaded up the game
I didn't know exactly where I was so I
thought they were like five on the
lamppost but that's not true here's the
one on the fence here this is the only
one on the fence there's only one on the
fence there's only two or three on the
lampposts and it all generally doesn't
go anywhere so when you round the bend
after this one you'll come to a path if
you go to the right there's a tree in
the middle of the thing here and there's
nothing that way so you know that's a
way you don't go and then if you round
the bend here you pass this light you go
for a ways off until you reach another
either another lamppost or another
branching path I can't remember which
one comes up next I think it's a
branching path oh no it's a lamppost
okay so this lamppost also has a page
and then there's only two left and so
the last page is actually if you take
the next branching path it goes up to a
dead end
whoa I looked at you don't be sassing
with me so if you over here there's a
dead end but it does have a lamppost on
the end of it and you grab this one
because it's so there's a total of three
on the lampposts and then you want to go
back the other way
to the other end which also reaches a
dead end but this is literally the end
of the entire pathway so there's nothing
more off of here you reach the dead end
with two rocks you'll notice it's the
only one with two rocks all the other
ones have multiple rocks you make sort
of a left and you look for a pair of two
trees and bam you got all the pages and
that's how you do and then you let cheek
come up and give you a big old victory
hug cuz she's a beaut and you love her
to pieces and she's gonna love me to
pieces in just a hot second here and
then you beat the game so that is how
you beat chica and that is the special
secret behind the joy of creation easy
peasy lemon squeezy
right great so oh man
I I don't even know anymore I've at such
a time trying to get this to work and
man oh man I I'm gonna go relax and then
get you guys a second video that's what
I owe you and that's what I'm gonna get
you
once again I'm very sorry for the delay
I have been absolutely slammed I've been
losing sleep like every night I'm not
trying to make excuses I'm just trying
to paint the picture of why things have
been off schedule with me going
last-minute to the wedding which I
didn't even know I was gonna go to until
Friday and I left Saturday so man it's
been a time but I am working hard to get
these videos to you guys I promise it'll
be back on schedule soon I've just been
going out of my mind with work but it's
all for you guys that I'm happy to do it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in